oi gente bom dia
então a gente conversar e que repetir
aqui vocês telefônica que as suas
cabeças e não vem em duas versões 500
vamos lá ganhando a luta pelo lugar
é o mesmo que rápida
a gente escolhe quais não concorda
quando eles estavam na prova
[Aplausos]
o lugar tem também o desconforto que
milhares de pessoas quando justin é
fácil por isso eu sair e deixar tudo
para trás a família amigos sonho sua
dívida e ainda quando chega a sair de
suas vidas não chegando aqui de volta
[Música]
os comentários são reais e foram
retiradas da internet brasileira vivo de
raça nacionalidade
[Música]
o funcionamento e também fica muito a
vida daquelas pessoas que vêm do brasil
na proteção da vida como a famosa 0
a família não sei
na internet como é difícil
no brasil a idade
[Música]
hoje em dia no mundo 20 milhões
é diferente mas o número
a gente não pode porque na série de tv
ele escolhe uma coisa nova
pintou no primeiro eletricista
cozinheiro na cozinha tudo considera a
melhor cozinheira do mundo em qualquer
lugar
além de tudo isso ele não fala árabe e
em inglês um pouquinho de coreano
é mais lenta nas ruas
o governador é de que a resposta vem com
throw eu fui seu estilo ele tem 16 anos
da república
apesar do nome o país menos democrático
e mais violentos do mundo e hoje vive
uma guerra civil que já dura anos e já
deixou mais de 60 países
o pai foi preso apenas o brasil abriu as
portas sem falar uma palavra de
português
não sei se já é fã
ele conhece nosso país do futebol cinco
anos de história quando aprendeu que o
brasil é mais uma peça por indígenas
europeus que deram ao chegar ele
encontra o brasil ainda mais diversas
hoje ele é muito jovem e hoje tem a
chance de mostrar
esta é diferente não é conseguir estar
na escola magia
[Música]
ela tinha
ae qual a bola como voltarei a lacuna de
vida
16 na escola e aí você imagina internet
o dinheiro na internet e foi um completo
sucesso reais
são mais de 36 mil pessoas e hoje
[Música]
o público também é i mostra cultural e
realizar diversos momentos atuais de
pobrezas feito traz mais de dois mil
alunos e hoje
ele comunicou ontem que vai me cobrar
central se tornou professor jorge py
mesmo dia ele a coordenadora de uma
escola
ele é um dos profissionais mais um tempo
junto da minha filha e hoje ao inglês
árabe coreano ele também fala português
fluentemente e amanhã um pouquinho
desejo de negócio
[Aplausos]
o dinheiro estava um bom terreno do
esmalte e no final wellington voltando
pra lá que o time pode sair da sala de
aula e esgoto e sempre
[Música]
a família nardoni no acostamento direito
em uma faculdade permite a chamada são
paulo encerram no colo dele sobre a
história da vida dele
[Aplausos]
pessoas que já viveram muito em dia é
perceptivo receber o único futuro que
vale a pena ser construído
[Aplausos]